[Music]
on this sunday night show of force
time to go home police ramp up measures
at the ambassador bridge how soon
traffic could be back to normal growing
resistance
ottawa residents clash with protesters
frustrated police aren't doing more we
want them to be punished deepening
tension in ukraine the united states is
prepared our allies are prepared the
concern for loved ones who might be
caught in the line of fire and canadian
caretaker why he's trading his skates
for solitude on a tiny irish island
[Music]
global national
reporting tonight chris galas
good evening and thanks for joining us
police are finally making some progress
at the ambassador bridge blockade but
the effort to restore the flow of goods
at canada's busiest border crossing has
fallen short so far our sean o'shea was
there as police moved in and made some
arrests sean
chris police faced some criticism for
not being able to clear the blockade on
saturday so today their tactics were
slightly different
just before dawn sunday morning a man
holds a flag as he looks out on police
behind him a small group of protesters
who stayed out here all night
the remnants of a group that stopped
traffic on the ambassador bridge linking
ontario and michigan over the past week
disrupting the two countries most
important trade link
on saturday after police arrive big rigs
and most other vehicles gave up on the
blockade
only a few refused to leave like these
two pickup trucks police didn't push
them out at first something business
groups said was urgently necessary these
disruptions in canada have an impact on
the united states that's why the us is
paying very close attention to this
this morning the approach was different
police weren't asking protesters to
leave they were telling them
police approached the drivers of the two
trucks when they refused to leave police
arrested them both
at the same time as they ordered
reporters recording their operation to
leave that way behind the barricade i'm
walking
back to barricade now please
further up the roadway larger trucks
were told to leave and they did without
any resistance
the police are
puppets of the state which i don't think
it's going to end for a while but it's
going to end police later fanned out in
a private parking lot and ordered
everyone to move their vehicles
threatening to tow away those who didn't
small in number they just won't go away
causing police to remain on the roadway
police made more arrests this afternoon
because despite their efforts more
protesters kept coming out at this point
the ambassador bridge remains closed and
officials say it will reopen only when
it's safe to do so chris
sean o'shea in windsor ontario thank you
very much sean breaking news out of
ottawa tonight where the mayor says he's
reached a back channel deal with protest
organizers to limit their demonstration
to the area immediately surrounding
parliament hill the agreement calls for
vehicles to roll out of residential
neighborhoods over the next 24 hours and
as abigail beeman explains the deal is
welcome news for ottawa residents fed up
with the three-week protest
don't provoke thanks
fed up ottawa residents fill several
intersections trying to block protest
vehicles headed downtown the almost
incomprehensible failure of leadership
in this city took a bunch of random
citizens being annoyed to actually stop
trucks and not
lease this video shows two vehicles that
kept rolling as people got in front of
them they hit me i was so
shocked that somebody would do that
i know i was standing in the road and
that's not allowed but they've been
blocking streets for two weeks now
late sunday a potential breakthrough
ottawa's mayor released letters showing
convoy leadership agreed to move out of
residential zones and stick to
parliament hill police pegged the crowd
at 4 000 saturday here at the war
memorial the fencing that surrounded the
site remains down saturday a group of
protesters many who appeared to be
veterans or wearing medals camouflage or
berets took down that fencing the office
of the minister of public services and
procurement says pspc put up the
original fencing and they plan to
replace it as soon as they're told it's
safe to do so but as of sunday no
offense we'll put a man on it next one
this is all you guys
many concerned about hands-off policing
including handing off responsibility for
guarding the memorial to the protesters
and this time lapse video shows there
wasn't always someone at the war
memorial overnight concerned too about
the views of some of those involved
they're trying to say that the guys are
you know they're all waving it's a nazi
salute
that's so desperate and insane and um
and then the police didn't do anything
because they know it's ridiculous they
know themselves it's ridiculous in this
video veteran jeremy mckenzie talks
about the importance of having free
access to the site he was recently
arrested for firearms violations in nova
scotia the canadian anti-hate network
flags him for among other things a live
stream about burning parliament down and
his phrase gun or rope for how to deal
with those ideologically opposed i think
we all have to recognize that you know
the harm that is being caused by these
individuals and it's not about people's
frustration with the pandemic a comment
from bill blair that directly
contradicts every person we've spoken to
on ottawa streets we're spreading love
because we are the focus of the world
right now ottawa
protesters maintain they're here
peacefully upset with coveted mandates
abigail beeman global news ottawa
during an interview on the west block
with mercedes stephenson emergency
preparedness minister bill blair hinted
that trudeau government is actively
considering using emergency powers to
end the blockades
we also are prepared to use whatever
legislative and resource tools and and
what i mean by that is every federal
resource
is
will be considered in order to protect
critical infrastructure and to keep
canadians safe the police have an
important job to do but there are other
jobs that also need to be done and we'll
make sure they get done are you prepared
to invoke the emergencies act
certainly i will tell you the
emergencies act has been under very
folsom consideration right from the
first day as as to what needs to be done
but the the emergencies act the federal
emergencies act is really contingent
upon the the provinces exactly
exhausting their authorities um and and
turning to us and saying we need more
blair says the federal government is
working with ontario to make sure the
province is in fact exhausting all
options the current iteration of the
emergencies act passed in 1988 has never
been used
the canadian forces is investigating
three serving members of an elite
military counterterrorism unit known as
joint task force two for allegedly
taking part in the protests in the
nation's capital in a statement today
the commander of the canadian special
operations forces command says quote i
expect our members to act in ways that
demonstrate canadian armed forces values
and ethics and to uphold them both on
and off duty global news has learned two
of the jtf2 special operations
assaulters refused to be vaccinated and
are in the process of being released
from duty
some provinces are moving forward with
their road maps out of this pandemic on
saturday quebec lifted limits on home
gatherings and on monday gyms will be
open again and sports leagues will be
back nova scotia will begin easing
restrictions in three phases starting
tomorrow including lifting border
restrictions for domestic travelers
vaccine passports are still required in
both provinces at least for now but not
in saskatchewan which as nathaniel dove
reports will drop its proof of
vaccination requirement at midnight
starting monday dale mckay won't know
the vaccination status of his customers
coming into his restaurants in saskatoon
and regina
and he's fine with that it is a bit of a
bit of a chore for restaurants and for
businesses to be checking passports
every time
we have a new guest come in since
october patrons were required to show
proof that they were fully vaccinated or
of a negative covert 19 test we chose
not to necessarily go with the negative
tests just because uh it just added
another level of kind of confusion when
was the test taken all that kind of
stuff but on monday the province is
dropping those requirements premier
scott moe said businesses who wish to
keep enforcing it must do so on their
own if a municipality or private
business wanted to move forward
with that policy
i suppose they should do so my advice
would be to consult a lawyer mckay is
accepting the change and that some
customers might have coveted like they
might have the flu
he says his staff will keep wearing
masks even after all other health orders
are dropped at the end of the month so
customers feel safe he just wants things
to go back to normal
but the virus that causes covet 19 is
still spreading this snapshot of the
health authority's internal covet 19
dashboard obtained by global news shows
nearly 400 people needing care
according to a recent doctor's update
the non-icu system is at capacity
and in the push to get to the living
with covid stage of the pandemic the
government stopped sharing daily updates
an infectious disease physician says
people need more information and now is
not the time to drop public safety
measures the challenge here again is
uh trying to sort of understand sort of
what the rationale for all of this was
you know and sort of what the rush was
wong is worried fewer people will get
their shots without the health order in
place
you need vaccines to live with covet
nathaniel dove global news saskatoon
at least a dozen countries including
canada and the u.s have told their
citizens to get out of ukraine as
western allies warn russian forces could
invade at any moment canadian military
trainers have been pulled out and are
now in poland and canadian embassy staff
in kyiv have also been relocated
jennifer johnson reports
a russian submarine spotted sailing
towards the black sea as russia's naval
aircraft troops and military equipment
surround much of ukraine u.s president
joe biden spoke with ukraine president
vladimir zelinsky sunday working on a
diplomatic solution to the crisis
zielinski is telling his citizens not to
show russia any fear or panic the best
friend for enemies that is panic in our
country
but fears are growing that a russian
invasion could happen as soon as this
week the united states is prepared our
allies are prepared and now it's up to
russia to determine what the next step
they will take is
ukrainians have taken to the streets
urging peace but many expecting an
invasion of course i'm worried but am i
afraid
not
the u.s is sending a total of 6 000
additional troops to eastern europe not
to enter a war but to defend nato
territory america and its nato partners
have repeatedly warned putin they will
shut russia off from billions of
international financial transactions
should russia invade the response in the
united states and our allies will be
swift
it will be united
it will be severe
but some experts believe putin is more
concerned about controlling ukraine once
part of the soviet union than punishing
economic sanctions
we think that putin's some kind of
rational actor calculating the cost
benefit analysis of invasion when in
fact he's thinking about his place in
the history books 50 years from now
diplomatic staff members from the u.s
canada and other nations are evacuating
or relocating a growing list of
countries have told their citizens to
get out parishioners at this indiana
church are concerned for their pastor
who went to ukraine for a family funeral
i'm not going to
go to the worst case scenario but we are
worried about him and his family
over 100 000 russian troops are amassed
on ukraine's border while others train
for battle in belarus russian missiles
are also prepared to launch a buildup of
firepower that could strike on very
short notice
jennifer johnson global news washington
up next tiny bugs causing big trouble
health experts battle a threat made
worse by the pandemic
[Music]
as if we needed it during the pandemic
there is another global health emergency
that's receiving little attention before
covid19 drug-resistant superbugs killed
more than 1.2 million people worldwide
in 2019. as candice daniel reports
experts say the superbug health crisis
has worsened during covit
jeff summer summerhays was born with
cystic fibrosis a degenerative disorder
that can cause severe damage to the
lungs to make things worse when jeff was
a teenager he also contracted a
bacterial infection it's a battle he's
been fighting for decades my
lung function has been deteriorating
about one to two percent a year since i
was 17.
he had been taking antibiotics to fight
it but the bug had adapted and evolved
rendering jeff's treatments useless
now the problem is
that these microorganisms are are smart
and so they develop resistance through
mutations and and such that allow them
to kind of circumvent what that
antibiotic is trying to do it's called
antimicrobial resistance or amr it's
when microorganisms become resistant
against treatments used to cure
infections including antibiotics and
experts say the pandemic has added to
the problem it's worsening under covid
because resources have been directed
away from antibiotic stewardship in
hospitals and so we're really behind the
eight ball another reason for this is
the misuse of antibiotics
to fight covid19 research from the
americas showed more than 90 percent of
patients admitted to hospital for covid
were prescribed an antimicrobial but
only seven percent needed them certainly
there have been a couple of studies that
have shown that antibiotic-resistant
organisms in hospital settings have been
on the rise through this pandemic
as for jeff after years of having cf and
a superbug his lungs were ravaged he
needed a double lung transplant to live
jeff says the doctors told him the
superbug would make his surgery more
dangerous
we knew going in that the the big battle
would be the bacterial battle there's
only a 50 chance of survivability one
year post-transplant
despite the odds he had the life-saving
transplant in 2018. jeff knows if his
antibiotic-resistant superbug causes a
flare-up again it's likely there are no
more drug treatment options to keep him
alive what's the feeling that you carry
with you along with the odds every day
of your life
right now it's gratefulness
i'm still here
candace daniel global news
next on global national with valentine's
day approaching new research shows which
gender is hit harder by heartbreak
[Music]
as many canadians prepare to celebrate
valentine's day with their partners
others might be newly single fresh off a
breakup and alone
a new study out of the university of
british columbia found when men leave a
relationship they seem to be at greater
risk of mental illness and as jamie
morocco explains the pandemic could be
making things worse
when toronto relationship coach roman
mironov's marriage ended seven years ago
he says he was devastated he fell into a
mild depression i felt like that was the
end of my life for for the first couple
of weeks i felt terrible and i just
didn't know what to do researchers from
the university of british columbia have
found when relationships break down men
are at an increased risk of anxiety
depression and even suicide compared to
women of 47 canadian and australian
participants 96 share those feelings and
accounts john oliver professor of
nursing and lead author on the study
says the risk of male suicide quadruples
after a marital separation
if we think about suicide prevention
and knowing that men's suicide at three
to four times the rate of women i think
it's such
a given that the relationship breakdowns
do put men at risk the covenant 19
pandemic is only making the situation
worse for many men the study found they
are turning to substance use drinking to
cope and because of social restrictions
they are losing close ties with friends
ottawa psychotherapist sean hale offers
sessions online and says he's seeing the
same thing in his practice after a
breakup
if you're feeling these emotions and you
can't get them out
they can lead into those kind of
feelings of depression because you're
kind of dealing with it on your own olaf
says there needs to be more mental
health care options geared to men he
hopes to see people reach out before a
breakup gaining valuable communication
and coping skills strategies for working
through those things and and splitting
amicably
and then working their way through
through those uh those challenging
situations mironov agrees the 39 year
old now has a new partner and uses his
experience to help others don't go into
that vicious cycle break out of it by
reaching out to someone a decision
experts say could be life-saving jamie
morocco global news toronto
coming up dream job how a canadian
former hockey player and his partner
became the caretakers of a remote irish
island
believing in yourself might just get you
to the olympic podium and that is
certainly the case for canada steven
dubois who added a bronze to his metal
count in 500 meters short track
following his skate dubois said he knew
he had the potential to win medals he
almost didn't qualify for the final
though after a collision with a south
korean skater but after review south
korea was penalized for an illegal late
pass and the rest is history
as we hopefully begin to emerge from the
pandemic many of us are eager to put
isolation behind us and resume our
normal lives but a former pro hockey
player from saskatchewan and his dutch
girlfriend are doing pretty much the
opposite they beat out thousands of
other applicants to become caretakers of
an uninhabited island off the coast of
ireland redmond shannon has their story
it's a shot at tips today
[Applause]
in a decade of minor league hockey brock
montgomery scored plenty of goals and
through his fair share of punches too
and there's going to be a fight
montgomery off the ice he practiced yoga
and mindfulness to deal with the stress
playing professionally in the
netherlands he met claire de haas
traveling together just before the
pandemic claire saw a job ad caretakers
wanted for summer cottages on a small
irish island i showed brock immediately
and then he said
where can we apply and we apply the next
day the only problem thousands of others
did too and then covered 19 hit
stranding them on an indonesian island
it was kind of surreal because we had
the island
to ourselves for a little bit there
something that will never happen again
they stayed there for months and
volunteered before heading to canada and
back to europe this year a few weeks ago
we got a message from them
if we were still in and we immediately
said yes now as restrictions ease for
the rest of us brock and claire are
going into self-imposed exile off the
grid for six months so there will be a
solar panel that gives us enough to
charge our phones our laptop and stuff
like that
and they bring food to us every day
although solar panels may only go so far
in an irish summer claire's always
joking that we're not made of sugar
she's dodged so yeah so we're expecting
we're expecting some rain seclusion has
perhaps one major challenge for any
couple it's like we're not we're not
leaving so yeah just have to get used to
it and enjoy not kill each other
that mindfulness training may come in
very handy and if brock ever feels
homesick he can just squint into the
atlantic sunset over the next island
over known here as the sleeping giant
next stop canada redmond shannon double
news london
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm chris galas tonight
your canada is peggy's cove nova scotia
thanks for watching everyone donna
friesen is back tomorrow hope you have a
great night
[Applause]
[Music]